what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talked about each sins animal tattoo and
the meaning behind them wise Milly Otis
is a dragon or bonds of Fox or s nor is
a lion I've always been fascinated by
these animal specific tattoos and why
each sin got the one they did so I'm
extremely glad that I finally get to do
this video and explore in detail how
every sin relates to their specific
animal if you like seeing seven deadly
sins videos on this channel make sure to
smash that like button and share this
video with a friend leave suggestions
for future seven deadly sins videos you
would like to see in the comments below
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell because you will miss some of the
loose ends videos if you don't for more
seven deadly sins content and updates on
new seasons follow us on instagram at
anime up drawer where you can let me
know who has the best animal tattoos
there will be manga spoilers in this
video you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into it so how
did the sins actually get the tattoos on
their bodies well in volume 5 of the
manga it's revealed that the tattoos
were created by Merlin they're the
result of a magic spell rather than a
tattoo machine however what interests me
more than how they got the tattoos on
their bodies is how they each relate to
their specific animal it's interesting
if they're all associated with a
specific animal in the first place
the ten commandments are not associated
with specific animals and in other
series often the seven sins are not
either
for instance in Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood they refer to lust greed
gluttony and so on but they don't
associate each one with an animal the
fact that the sins are so clearly
associated with animals in a not
sanitized eye is a unique and purposeful
choice by the manga Kanaka bouzouki that
is worth exploring in more detail now
let's start with Mellie Otis and drag
instead of wrath dragons are extremely
strong mythical creatures stronger than
any real animals
Dustin makes sense Emily oldest would be
so powerful and a leader of the seven
deadly sins the other sins are all
associated with real world animals since
Mellie Otis has the only mythical one it
rightaway sets him apart as different
and he is different as we figure out
later on in the series because he's a
demon from the demon realm the different
views people have of dragons also
captures the different sides of Mellie
Otis in your
in tradition dragons symbolize chaos and
evil malleolus started out seeming
pretty evil and brutal when he was the
leader of the ten commandments the
goddess Elizabeth changed him but Mellie
Otis still continues to have moments of
Wrath where he blacks out and causes
insane amounts of damage and destruction
to his surroundings case in point the
kingdom of Danna for if we turn from
Europe and look at the way the Far East
viewed dragons it's very different
they were often associated with positive
things like Fortran longevity and
authority the dragon was associated with
Emperor's so it makes sense that the
leader of the seven deadly sins would be
associated with a dragon - furthermore
as we find out Mele ODIs was thousands
of years old
is royalty himself he is the son of the
demon king and he was the heir to the
royal demon throne dragons are also
associated with being fearless
passionate intensely loyal and prone to
rage issues people associated with
dragons are supposed to have a great
sense of humor an old soul and a desire
to rise above all circumstances I think
you'll notice that Mele Otis fits the
bill nicely he's never afraid to find an
opponent no matter how strong he is so
loyal to Elizabeth that in the data book
the answer that Elizabeth is his
favorite animal and his favorite smell
among other things in short he's
Elizabeth obsessed and he would never go
for any other girl even though girls
seem to constantly throw themselves at
him
obviously he's known as the sin of wrath
because he is prone to rage issues he's
hilarious his soul is literally
thousands of years old and he desires to
rise above all circumstances in order to
free Elizabeth from her curves in order
to do so he is even willing to take on
the gods themselves
lastly the fact that melioidosis dragon
tattoo is eating its own tail represents
Ouroboros it represents infinity it's a
nod to howl malleolus doesn't age
because of his curse like the cyclical
symbol malleolus lived a cyclical kind
of existence for 3,000 years where he'd
watch Elizabeth die only to be
reincarnated to die again and so on and
so on the curse gives him immortality
and eternal youth
so that he cannot die and must live for
eternity unless he breaks the curse when
the curses form is finally revealed in
Chapter 306 it looks like an Ouroboros
made up of heads so from the beginning
Mele Otis's tattoo was hinting at his
identity
and at his curse which he was trying to
break throughout the series next let's
look at bond the Fox that have greed his
Fox tattoo is located above the left
side of his waist foxes along with pegs
are bonds favorite animal the Fox is
especially significant to bond because
of his backstory his biological parents
were terrible they made bond steal food
for them and would hit him if he tried
to eat or even sleep one day he met Chu
bago abandoned in prison they became
friends and Javan became the good father
figure that bond ever had the thing is
Giovanna was aware Fox and he had a
biological werefox son
so think werewolves except you're a fox
human hybrid rather than a wolf human
hybrid at one point G Mongols biological
son was in danger and he went to save
him but was too late he had left bond in
trouble in order to try and save his
biological son but bond never blamed him
for that he continued to think of him as
his true father and even felt that he
was the best father that anyone could
have asked for in this sense it is
fitting that bond is the Fox and because
a where Fox was one of the most
important people in his life in fact the
thing that bond is the most embarrassed
about in his whole life is that he felt
all fuzzy inside when zhivago called him
his son beyond his Fox father let's look
at some other ways bond is associated
with foxes boxes are associated with
craftiness and being skilled in
deception in fact a synonym for
craftiness is foxiness you can see this
quality in bonds childhood as a bandit
and in his special ability called snatch
which lets him rob stuff from his enemy
he can steal objects hearts and even
strength and speed making him an
extremely tricky opponent bond also has
pronounced canine teeth giving him a
thoughts like appearance the Fox is
associated being resourceful adaptable
and persistent and bond definitely is
all of these things he was able to
survive a terrible childhood and even
1000 years in purgatory no other human
can say that next let's look at King the
Grizzlies sin of sloth Kings bear tattoo
is located on the outside of his left
leg there are multiple ways in which
King is associated with bears the most
obvious is that his sacred treasure
often takes the form of a bear at this
point in the manga Shasta full second
form looks like a giant buff green bear
with many arms and what looks like a
freakin 12
this form or that makes up for any
muscles that king is missing another way
that King is associated with bears is
that he quote-unquote hibernated for a
period of time he's called the sin of
sloth for a reason because he wasn't
there when his people needed him now to
be fair his memory was erased so it's
not really his fault
nevertheless since he was quote-unquote
sleeping on his kingly duties like a
bear might sleep through winter he was
given the sin of sloth next let's talk
about the end the Serpent's sin of envy
her serpent or snake tattoo is located
high up on her left outer thigh in some
cultures snake symbolized the umbilical
cord joining humans to mother earth
snakes since they stood there on the
ground are often associated with the
earth that's perfect for Deanne since as
a giant she's an earthbender and has a
very close connection to mother earth
many people are afraid of snakes just
like many people would fear the end
because she is a giant also on the giant
note there are serpents ak's snakes that
are freaking huge
when I did my one-piece video on zone
fruits I researched boa sander Sonia and
found out that she ate the heavy heavy
Noemi model anaconda fruit senator Sonia
is gigantic when she transforms and this
makes sense since the green anaconda is
one of the world's largest snakes and
can reach more than 17 feet the longest
recorded specimen was a female that
reached over 18 feet long Deanne is
thirty feet tall so she's even bigger
but the point is that she is huge just
like her tattoo animal can be perhaps
the most obvious connection is that
snakes or serpents are associated with
jealousy and temptation that is the ant
defining trait in the beginning which
makes sense since she is the set of
enemy after all in the beginning the
Anne tries to tempt meliodas and gets
jealous of Elizabeth
even though Mellie Otis and Elizabeth
are obviously an item and she should be
turning her attention elsewhere when she
finally regains her memories though and
remembers that she loves King she is
largely cured of her jealousy problem
next we shall talk about the one the
only
ESCA nor de Lyonne scent of pride
himself eskimos tattoo is right on his
back and it is the biggest in proportion
to his body the lion is concerned to be
king of the beasts and as a result and
is associated with kingly power and
might as we know Eska nor was born into
royalty
he was a prince of the Costello Kingdom
and as far as mite goes he was
considered to be the strongest of the
sins when he was introduced lions are
also associated with pride and courage
both of which perfectly describe daytime
eScan or esker nor believed that he was
greater than Kings who were as numerous
as grains of sand while he was like no
other even though he was a human aka a
member of the weakest clan he believed
that he stood atop all clans at the
pinnacle of all living things it doesn't
get much more prideful than that I
challenge you to name me a more prideful
character than Eskin or in the comments
as far as courage goes he not only
fought against assault mode Melly Otis
he insisted on it he was even willing to
fight the demon king there is not one
opponent that day time has gonna refuse
to fight out of fear he is excited by
the idea of a strong opponent rather
than scared by it and that's one of the
biggest reasons he's so epic next let's
look at go thir the goat sin of lust his
tattoo is located below his right
collarbone the goat has been associated
with vitality health sensuality virility
and lust as far as health goes since go
through a doll he's pretty much immortal
he doesn't age and he can't get sick
from his backstory it also seems like he
can make love he made love to the
princess Nadja before she passed away
from her sickness and then got
wrongfully imprisoned and accused of
lust aside from making love goat her
might even possess the ability to have
kids as well in theory dolls shouldn't
be able to have kids with humans but in
the seven deadly sins trees can give
birth to fairies and humans and fairies
can have babies so I wouldn't be
surprised if Co thir could actually have
kids either the world of the seven
deadly sins clearly doesn't follow the
rules of our own goats are also
associated with curiosity and
intelligence Goethe er especially since
his memories are erased for a large
portion of the series is very curious
about everything like a child seeing the
world for a first time he reads many
books in order to learn more about
humans and human emotions as far as
intelligence goes he has the insane
level of intelligence that has created a
demon go through had he is easily one of
the smartest characters in the series
that is why he's usually trying to
develop emotional intelligence because
his IQ is more than high enough as is
last but not least let's look at Merlin
the Boursin of gluttony
her bore tattoo is located on the left
side of her neck a bore is a wild pig
and it's definitely a good choice for
the sin of gluttony you've probably
heard the saying you eat like a pig
the idea is that you overindulge you eat
more than you need to and more than is
healthy Merlin is a glutton for
knowledge rather than a glutton for food
though even the knowledge of the known
realms wasn't enough her goal became to
revive chaos who created the demon king
supreme deity the sacred tree Giants and
humans so that chaos would give rise to
virtually limitless unknown things she
hoped that her starved heart would then
be filled because there would be so many
more new things to learn about she's
such a glutton for new knowledge that
she purposely put the other sins in
danger in order to achieve her goal and
revive chaos along with representing
abundance courage and power the boar
represents stubbornness conflict and
disorder it doesn't get much more
abundant than infinity which is Merlin's
magic even as a child she was more
powerful and talented than the wise men
of her hometown of beli allowin and as
far as courage goes Merlin was always
ready to face strong opponents and even
went out of her way to help revive the
demon king in chaos she was a stubborn
as' in that she stuck with her ultimate
goal even after she made friends with
the sins after all their adventures she
was still willing to put them in danger
and even though a second or loved her
and melly ODIs never would she could
never get over her feelings for Mellie
Otis because of those feelings she was
even willing to bring herself into
conflict with the people who were
closest to her this island deadly sins
and it's easy to connect Merlin with
disorder since her end goal was disorder
she wanted to revive chaos which would
mean this order on the largest scale
possible
lastly heard that to always look like
Hawk and his mama as we recently found
out in the manga this was a huge clue
about her secret intentions Hawks mama
was chaos
so Merlin literally had her goal stamped
on her neck she wanted to fully revive
the thing called chaos that was inside
the pig shaped shell of moss
we called hawks mama the board truly was
the perfect animal for Merlin and she
knew that when she used magic to create
her tattoo along with the others and
that is it for today's video thank you
so much for watching if you had to pick
one favorite animal tattoo
one would you pick I'm sure that a lot
of SDS fans already had tattoos like
this if I were a tattoo guy myself I'd
probably pick bonds Fox one it's very
cool and very sly if you want to see
every character sin rather than their
animals explained in more detail you can
check that out in my seven deadly sins
playlist I'll link it at the end of this
video but for this one I thought it
would be cool to talk about the animal
specifically and I did enjoy that it
seems like there are good reasons for
each animal and they weren't just picked
at random if you notice some connections
that I didn't feel free to leave them in
the comments if you did enjoy this video
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future videos for more SDS content
and updates on new seasons falls on
instagram ant and me uproar where you
can let me know who has the best animal
tattoo a special thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero to
your patrons the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson kings al
just fitted ala beats alpha do
Anatoli Kazansky angel Cruz team Sparky
65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor Taku Timothy
edward vargas & gell turn and are the
one tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans Steven agraja Aloha autumn
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus and Tyson Corino thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you could
support more by going over to
patreon.com/scishow and Meowth floor and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access for a private
patron only discourse where we talk
about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon combination
if you're interested you can also now
join the YouTube channel and support
more content that way if you prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]